today i'm going to talk about some
interesting new vulnerabilities in the
node.js ecosystems
the talk will be divided into three
parts
first i will introduce the technical
details of the new vulnerabilities
and discuss the exploitation then
i will talk more about the bike bug
finding parts
which is about the lessons and the
insights
from building uh one kind of a tour
to detect and exploit hpa
and in the last part i will give up
impact analyzes of the new risk and some
evaluation data
about the tools
so first of all let's take a quick look
at the vulnerabilities we found during
our research
so in total we discovered 13 zero-day
vulnerabilities from widely used
programs such as mongodb visual drivers
class validators
and this box can be exploited to launch
serious attacks
such as leaking credential data
bypassing security checks
and denying services
so before we touch the technical details
of these vulnerabilities
let's have a brief background
introduction about the node.js
node.js is for executing javascript code
outside of browsers
the picture on the right is the overall
system diagram of node.js
to interrupt and execute javascript
the node.js implements a runtime engine
based on chrome v8
to satisfy the needs of the host the
server-side languages
the the runtime engine also provides a
set of api to let javascript
interact with the host environment
by providing such apis the javascript
code can access the host environments
like any other server side languages
for example he can read and write file
systems
or execute execute system command so
node.js is pretty powerful
nowadays many websites are deployed in
node.js
for example node.js are intensively used
in companies
like paypal and linkedin also we are
all using a lot of electron apps such as
skype or
skulks discord and search electron apps
are also based on node.js runtime
we've seen so many node.js applications
the web-based app
are the one of the most common types of
node.js programs
for those web-based applications taking
the communication data into object
representations like json
is pretty pretty common
and this feature is convenient
for example the node.js can use this
feature to send
and receive very complex data structure
from the monthly download statistic
picture on the right
we can have an idea of how the object
sharing is being supported
and used by the node.js ecosystems
so the diagram that demonstrates how the
object sharing is being used
in the node.js ecosystem there are two
major methods of serialization
object datas the first is the query
stream based serialization
and the second is the json-based
civilization as shown in the picture
if the user wants to update the age
information in the node.js web
he can send his data either via standard
query string in the url
or json string in the request body
upon receiving the request the web
application will convert
the json data or the query string data
into an object so that the object can
further propagate in the program logics
okay so basically this is how the object
sharing is
carried out in node.js ecosystems
usually
if we want to evaluate the security of
such a program
we may want to inject different payloads
into the age field
so that we can try to trigger
certain vulnerabilities such as circle
injections or cross-site scripts
however what if we choose not to test
the existing data field
since we can pass an object into the
program what will happen if we inject
additional properties
that are not expected to be received by
the server program
in particular if an attacker can send
the properties that
forge or override the certain internal
program states
the attacker may easily obtain dangerous
abilities
to manipulate the key program logics
so we are going to introduce the hidden
property of using
hpa so the hidden property of using
leverage the object sharing in node.js
to tamper
or forge critical program states
we call the additional properties we
inject as the hidden properties
because these properties are kind of
like some hidden parameters
which is valid to the endpoint user api
these these parameters are associated
with certain internal program states
however nobody knows their existence
until an
attacker leverage hpa to temper the
states
in this talk we mainly focus on the
server-side scenarios
where a remote attacker wants to attack
the node.js web applications
or some microservices to explore the
vulnerabilities the attacker
will access the legitimate interfaces
such as the web api
endpoint to send his payloads in most
cases
the attacker payloads should be in the
form of plan
object which is the simplest object
representation in node.js
during our research we discovered two
type of typical
attack vectors of hpa we call the first
one as the app specific attribute
manipulation
this one is for manipulating certain
internal properties defined by the
application themselves
search internal properties are supposed
to be initialized and managed by their
internal functions
however they usually represent certain
internal states of the programs
so as shown in the picture the ioit row
is an internal function that is
responsible for maintaining the access
right
on the user object however
with hpa the attacker can propagate a
conflicting
name properly to the use object and
thus the control the internal states of
the program
as shown in the picture the the program
also provides an api
called update this is for external usage
however if a malicious user injects
additional key value pair which is
access
and admin in the picture to the
api then the the additional properties
will override the existing
access right so this payload is pretty
useful
when we want to abuse certain concrete
logics in large
applications such like some older
informations
or user privilege any management logics
also hpa can target some unique
javascript schemes
such as prototyping we call the second
attack scenarios as
prototype inheritance hijacking
in javascript every object has a link to
a prototype object
when the javascript code wants to access
a property
of an object the property will not only
be searched
on the object but also the product of
the object
and even the prototype of the prototype
until our property with a matching name
is found
as shown in the picture when the
javascript code wants to get the
constructive constructor property from
the input object
it will first search locally within the
input object
since there is no property named
constructor here
the code will continue its search to his
prototype
where the constructor is really located
so with hpa we can hijack the
inheritance chain
and forge our own payloads as the
internal
properties on the chain as shown in the
picture
if we inject a property named
constructor
the search process will be very
different since there is already a
property named constructor within the
input object
the search will immediately stopped
and end up with retaining a user
controlled value
as demonstrated in the red circle the
value of the constructor will become a
string
rick and morty rather than normal
javascript functions
so the second attack vector is really
useful when
because we found many javascript
developers tend to trust the properties
inherited from prototypes and make many
security sensitive decision
decisions based on them also we should
be aware of the differences between
these attack vectors with the prototype
pollution
the two are the two attacks totally
different
the prototype pollution as the name
suggested is about tampering
tempering the prototype object however
our attack vector does not modify the
prototype object
the root cause of the hpa is that the
node.js fails to
isolate the unsafe object such as the
user input
from the critical internal states
so to make a clear classification the
hpa
can be seen as a new security risk under
the common weakness
category 915 whose child
variants are all about improper
modification
of the dynamic object attributes
as shown in the hierarchy tree on the
right there are some similar issues on
other language platforms
such as ruby mass assignment the php
object injections
although these variants share the same
behavior feature dominated by 915
they all have their common their own
data patterns due to the language
differences
for example the roof the ruby mass
assignment is a set of vulnerabilities
discovered
in widely used ruby web application
framework called
ruby on rails unlike hpa
the attacker does not pass objects into
the program
instead the attacker abused a
framework specific assignment feature in
ruby on rails
to modify certain existing objects on
the right side of the assignment
and the payloads between the two attacks
are also different
the mass assignment payloads are literal
value
however hpa can introduce hidden
properties within
with either literal value or nested
object form
more importantly the ruby is strongly
typed so the mass assignment
vulnerabilities cannot introduce new
properties to the objects
however the hpa can inject arbitrary
arbitrary properties which make hpa
really flexible and powerful
okay so with several pages of concept
introduction
i think it's time we can hack some real
targets
in this example we target at a popular
popular web framework named rooting
controller
we will attack its official example code
to demonstrate an n2m prototype
inheritance hijack exploit
from security check by passing to cycle
injection
the figure on the right can give you a
brief idea on how our example works
in the example a server program is
deployed
using rooting controllers if a remote
user wants to authenticate with the
server
his data will flows into the following
components
first he will send his serialized data
into the
authentication module then
the authentication module will
instantiate our objects according to the
json he provides
and send it to the param handler here we
use the green box to demonstrate the
user data objects
the para handler is responsible for
ensuring user input object is not
malicious
the handler will first collect internal
format specification object
which is the blue box in the picture and
he will merge
the specification with the input object
and invoke the input validation api
the input validation api will synthesize
the user input data according to the
format specification
in this case it will check if the email
field is legitimate or not
if the check pass the user object will
flows into the database
okay so this is the overall data flow
let's analyze how we can attack the
logic step by step
so the first step is the hidden property
injection
in which the malicious attacker injects
a
hidden properties in his request
which is the constructor in this case as
shown in the picture
when the server program instantiates the
user object
there will be there will be additional
property named the constructor
which is a payload for bypassing the
input validation module
so in the second step the program will
prepare the parameters
needed by the input validation api the
server program will merge the user input
which is the param with the which with
our
object named scammer the merging
operation is carried out by
putting every property from the parent
objects into the scam object
so this process is very much like object
or assign
to simplify the demonstration let's just
use
object assign in this example by
performing search
merging operations the hidden property
constructor will also
transform to the scammer
and after the transformation we now can
hijack the inheritance of the
constructor on the scammer
actually the constructor of the scanner
plays a very important role
in the input validation module as shown
in the picture
the constructor actually stores the
for important format restriction
information
as a result the merging operation
enables us to hijack
the inheritance of these important
format restrictions
as shown in the picture when the
constructor is read
by the getscammer function our
hidden property will immediately match
and return to the code
to bypass the input validation we just
need to set the format
specification as an invalid value so
that our circle injection payload can
escape the check
now the last step is much more
straightforward
the validate payload then flows into the
sensitive api
to finish the entire attack so this is
how our entire hpa
chain looks like actually the code
logics behind the vulnerability is much
more complex
for example the input validation model
contains three thirty thousand thirteen
thirty thousand lines of code so it
would be helpful if we can find a tool
that automatically track these data
structures and discover harmful hidden
properties
exist in the program logics
so what are the challenges of building
such a tool
first of all it is javascript analyzing
javascript is known to be hard due to
the dynamic nature
and second hpa is a tech that
creates unexpected and new data
dependencies
however program analyze usually
such as data flow tracking is mainly for
analyzing the
existing flows third from our run
examples
we can observe that hpa tampers internal
program states
so the attack effects highly depends on
the roles of the
compromised states this makes the
detection more challenging
to overcome these challenges we design
and implement
linx a hybrid javascript program analyze
tool
to detect and exploit hpa
vulnerabilities
links mainly consist of two components
the first component on the left is for
identifying potential hidden properties
it combines it combines dynamic data
flow tracking
and static synthetics analyze to
track all the user input and infer
potential candidates
and the components on the right is for
detecting the harmful hidden properties
and generating exploits for them
to help future node.js security research
we decided to open source our links
project
at the github github links in the bottom
so if you are interested in the
technical details
you can check it in the github report
so the very first things links will do
is dynamic data flow tracking
first of all links will generate a label
object which is
which is a unique key and value p
links will inject the label into the u
input data of the program
since different properties from the
input object may flow
into different program logics we want to
and we want to track all these
propagations so we perform
the object the label injection in a
recursive minor
that is as shown in the picture on the
left
links will generated three different
inputs
by label injecting the original test
case
in each time links will inject the label
into a different properties
after the injection links will observe
the program execution
we leverage a javascript analysis
framework called jalanki
to instrument our test programs since
we are studying the data flow we
instrument the variable reads and writes
object property indexing and function
calls
then we execute the test program during
the execution
links will examine every object within
the data flow
if an object carries our property labels
we will record it for further analysis
so now we have a list of property
carriers
recall that the an object is flagged as
a property carrier because
we detect our injected label under his
body
so if we can properly propagate our
label here
maybe we can also propagate another
malicious
properties here also more specifically
if we can inject a property that has a
conflicting name
with certain internal property the
program has
maybe we can control that property by
overwriting them
so now we want to extract all the child
properties from the original
programs of the property carriers
and flag them as hidden property carry
candidates
to achieve this goal we need to steady
we need static syntax analyze to extract
the necessary syntactic information
from the code the picture on the left
right demonstrates how we pass our
statement from our run
example links will traverse the syntax
tree
until reaching a property carrier which
is circled by the red line in the graph
then it records all the properties under
the carrier
in in our case the hidden property
candidate is the constructor
so here is an output scripture
of the first component as you can
observed the links will first instrument
the code based
and then we tracked 43 property carriers
as indicated by the red circle links
successfully detect a hidden property
named constructor
so in previous component we discovered
the key name of the potential hidden
properties
by injecting a property with the same
key we might override certain internal
states
however we still don't know whether the
candidates can be controlled or not
and we also don't know how to introduce
attack effects
with these candidates so apparently
links could do more
let's revisit our run example to see if
there is any
insights to help us to design such an
exploitation component
the figure on the left is the vulnerable
code from our run
example as we have discussed many times
hidden probably tempers internal program
states
which means hpa exploitation highly
relates it to the code context
so it is important to conclude a set of
vulnerable
sensitive behaviors this behavior too
should clearly indicate certain security
consequences
so that we can decouple the harmfulness
detection from the code context
also from the running example the
exploitation is mainly about
manipulating the
written result more specifically there
are two possible passes
here if the execution enter the branch
online
line 19 we will get a validation failed
but we if we can go into the line 21
we can successfully pass the check
so the exploitation point and the
override override point
may not be the same place which means we
shouldn't stop
our analyze at line 11 instead
we should continue exploring all the
possible passes
that can be triggered by manipulating
the hidden properties
so we studied and concluded six general
type of sensitive
things due to the time constraint
i will not introduce the details of each
types
if you want to know more you can check
our git report
so after defining our sensitive sinks we
want the hidden property
to trigger as many as possible branches
and monitor whether we can hit a sink to
achieve this goal
we use symbolic execution to explore all
the hidden property value space
links first generate a exploit template
that can reach the potential hidden
vulnerable
property we denote such data structure
as a exploit template
because this is
links does not specify a concrete value
in the in the
input instead we insert a special
placeholder
which is which will be used by the
symbolic execution later on
then we run the test program with our
constructed templates
thus and symbolically executing the
hidden
property as shown in the picture the
links will
explore all the past constraints along
the
input path and once
if if links found that it had hit or
sync
for example in this example it hit the
sync i2
then he will fetch the corresponding
payload that can
trigger the sync as the final exploit
so a little background about the sync i2
is the sync we defined to detect that
whether our input can manipulate the
return value of a module or not
so this is the output of the exploit
module
from the circuit area we can observe
that the key value pair
constructed n1 triggered the sync i2
in the last line we can find that the
links successfully bypass
generator exploit that can lead to the
successful validation
so this is pretty much about how our
system work
let's see some interesting new results
of our research
during our research we choose 60 widely
used programs from node npm
there are 55 modules and five web
applications
and with the help of links we tracked
more than
1 300 carriers and detected three
more than 300 hidden property candidates
associated with those
carriers in the end we confirmed 1301
abilities
with the help of symbolic execution
links even synthesized can
exploit automatically
so how is the impact of these
vulnerabilities we found that hpa can
introduce various attack effects
such as leaking credential data
denial of services or bypassing the
security checks
based on the impact analysis we can
observe that the hpa can compromise
previously on reachable program states
which effectively enlarge the attack
surface
more even more we could notice that
httpa is not a simple input validation
issue and many input validators
themselves also vulnerable to hpa
so in the following slides i will pick
up two interesting vulnerabilities from
our result
and case studying them
so the first case comes from mongodb
official driver
we find that we can temporary internal
state
named the basin type a background here
is that
bsn or the mongodb leverage the internal
state vision type
to indicate the data type the data type
of the query object
however when serializing the query
object
mongodb will ignore the object with
unknown decent type
so what if we abuse the logic for a
qrecondition object the code on the
right
is from open source online game the
online game uses a vulnerable api to
implement the user management logics
as shown in the picture by injecting the
unknown bison type to the input
the attacker can force the mongodb not
serializing the curiosity condition
so that the mongodb will always return
the you the first use on top of the
database with this ability the attacker
can log in
or delete
arbitrary accounts
the second case is from another widely
used e-memory database
the hidden property is more like a back
tool which helps the user accessing
the sensitive data so in taffydb
we discover a hidden property named id
which is an internal index for each
database data item
once we specify our own id in the query
tafedb will ignore other query condition
and directly written the result
associated with the index so as shown in
the picture
even though we got wrong password and
username
we can still link the data from well
value the user data from
the database with our crafted hidden
properties
okay so thanks for attending our talk i
hope you guys keep safe
in this special year